which measurement is more accurate MRI or ultrasound. It depends on what your
journey to measure so okay so let's say if you go in okay here's a perfect
real-life example somebody told me the other day that they were having upper
right quadrant pain this was not a cancer patient and they suspected of
gallstones that history of gallstone issues went to the ER and they did a CT
scan and they said it's not gallstones maybe you have an ulcer that's what
they said and they center home and this person said I've had ulcers before
this is a did ulcers doesn't feel like an ulcer and they just said well we
don't know okay CT scan is not the test that you run for gallstones it
ultrasound is the test for gallstones why did they not do an ultrasound it's far
less expensive I hate to say I hate to be so cynical but her insurance probably
covered a CT scan and they made a whole bunch more money on a CT scan oh boy it's
this ridiculous so what you're looking for so an ultrasound is better for certain
things and MRI is better for other things more soft tissue things a CT scan is
much better for bony things like bony changes so if you are suspected like
metastasis of cancer to the lumbar spine the proper test would be a path scan
and a CT scan if you're suspected metastasis to the liver the proper test would
be an MRI or an ultrasound an MRI would show it better though if you're
suspecting gallstones the proper test is an ultrasound if you want to measure a
mass in your breast with with using the least amount of invasiveness then you'd
pick an ultrasound if you want to look for metastasis of a breast cancer if
you're suspecting bony metastasis you know again PET scan and a CT scan if you're
suspecting soft tissue metastasis it or in the lung a more proper test would
be an MRI there was an X-ray and any of those things that's what it would have
been you know 35 years ago but since they perfected an MRI and CT scan a PET
scan those have trumped that